un son Rook est puissant l'Espace
Rambouillet situé à son champ propose
aux aventuriers en herbe de venir
s'émerveiller en écoutant le brame du
cerf un grimarquant le début de la
saison des amours pour ce roi de la
forêt ce soir-là la vingtaine de
participants accompagnés d'un guide a pu
s'approcher de ses hard de ses vider
pendant environ deux heures toute
l'année le mal et la femelle ils vont
pas du tout être mélangés et au moment
de la période de production il va y
avoir une une très forte hausse de
testostérone chez le mâle et c'est ça en
fait qui va pousser le mal à se
rapprocher des femelles pour la
reproduction donc la testostérone c'est
l'hormone sexuelle donc c'est ça qui va
produire une hausse de son envie de se
reproduire finalement
repousser les adversaires marquer son
territoire et attirer les biches
silencieux le reste de l'année le serre
tire à se faire entendre jusqu'à
plusieurs kilomètres avec son brame une
période très éprouvante pour lui pendant
un mois donc il va presque pas manger
presque pas dormir il sera tout le temps
aux aguets pour surveiller la les
femelles en chaleur va avoir les autres
mâles autour qui ne sont pas dominants
qui vont rester quand même autour pour
ici que de quand même se reproduire avec
les femelles en chaleur restante un
autre mal répondu
jumelles et appareils photos pour
immortaliser ce moment privilégié les
curieux de nature ont pu s'approcher à
une cinquantaine de mètres de ces
animaux en semis liberté un spectacle
unique pour les petits et les grands à
l'approche de l'automne
on dirait un barrissement d'éléphant ou
un enregistrement d'un lion
bien sûr c'est toujours une chance de
pouvoir aller en Afrique ou ailleurs de
voir des animaux en liberté mais il n'y
a pas besoin finalement d'aller aussi
loin pour partager des instants
exceptionnels de vie sauvage à la photo
à l'évalière ici on peut les approcher
beaucoup plus près parce qu'ils sont un
peu habitués à voir les autres les
humains quoi et je trouve c'est
impressionnant une expérience à vivre le
matin ou le soir complété d'un petit
déjeuner ou d'un dîner au cœur du parc
rendez-vous jusqu'au 1er octobre 2023
pour entendre raisonner la magie de la
forêt